c'est honnête c'était un réel plaisir
vraiment d'être avec vous de partager
ces quelques moments d'après midi et je
remercie les organisateurs de m'avoir
donné l'occasion de me verser et de
m'immerger plutôt dans cette ambiance
jeunesse cet après midi alors il ya eu
les hommes il ya une la culture ce matin
il ya eu des sciences aussi il ya une
économie et moi je suis scientifique je
suis médecin je suis scientifique et
donc c'est de science que je vais parler
cet après midi alors y aura pas beaucoup
de jeux de mots peut-être pas et donc ça
va être un peu plus disons académique
voilà sans vouloir vraiment l'être sans
vouloir vraiment être alors on m'a
demandé de parler de l'humanité au futur
et avant de parler de l'humanité au
futur je voudrais tout simplement
rappelé comme je le fais à chaque fois
que je fais un speech ccoim d'humanité
l'humanité c'est tout simplement
l'ensemble des individus qui
appartiennent à l'espèce humaine
non seulement ça mais aussi des
caractéristiques particulières qui
définissent l'appartenance à cet
ensemble
donc ça c'est l'humanité avec un grand h
tout à l'heure dans la vidéo il y avait
autre chose
on avait parlé d' humanité en tant que
mots communs l'humanité en tant que mots
communs il désigne les traits d'un
individu qui amplifie les valeurs
caractéristiques essentielles à l'humain
cette grande famille des êtres humains
human being c'est en anglais est bien un
des sens d'un ancêtre commun et
aujourd'hui
elle se répartit sur la presque totalité
taire deux de la région terrestres du
globe et peut-être qu'un jour dans le
futur
elle va aller sur les autres planètes
mais malgré leurs origines communes et
ben les êtres humains se distinguent par
leur diversité diversité linguistique
diversité culturelle diversité même
physique la taille la couleur de la peau
la forme des yeux
par conséquent nous sommes tous des
parents mais nous sommes tous différents
en même temps alors l'humanité au futur
l'humanité futur commun ce qu'elle va
pouvoir exister elle doit sûrement
puiser dans son passé et se baser sur
son présent pour que l'humanité soit
comme honte
on souhaiterait que de soi au plus tard
eh bien il faudrait d'abord la préserver
il faudrait également lui donner les
ressources nécessaires il faudrait faire
de façon à la pérenniser c'est de notre
présent que dépend notre avenir et c'est
de notre pouvoir de faire de notre futur
ce que nous voulons dans toutes les
régions du monde sauf quelques
exceptions l'humanité a connu des
changements voire des bouleversements
dus aux modifications de son
environnement survenue à une vitesse
tellement rapide que si bien si l'un de
nos arrière arrière grand père venait à
visiter aujourd'hui il serait
complètement perdus entre alors
l'humanité
pourquoi elle a connu tous ces
changements parce que pendant des
décades pendant être même des siècles
elle a assimilé la révolution
industrielle mécanique informatique
biotechnologiques et bien d'autres et a
ainsi révolutionné ses us et ses
coutures rapport que généticienne j'ai
moi même vécu l'évolution de la
génétique qui a abouti à la révolution
des concepts et
à la manipulation du gênant d'ailleurs
quand j'ai pensé entreprendre des
spécialités en génétique on commençait à
peine à connaître comment une manipuler
l'adn et c'est seulement en 1978 que
l'équipe qui a découvert ce que l'on
appelle des enzymes de restrictions qui
sont tout simplement des ciseaux des
jets des ciseaux de l'adn et bien ils
ont reçu le prix nobel de médecine et de
physiologie d'ailleurs aussi quand j'ai
pensé faire métier est bien mais mes
camarades de promotion ne croyez pas
donc nous comprenait pas mon choix
et c'est pas seulement parce qu'on était
en tunisie même lorsque je m'étais
déplacé à paris pour parfaire ma
formation il a complété j'avais eu des
réflexes de réflexion dans le même sens
par des jeunes médecins français donc
c'est pour ça que je dis j'ai vécu
l'évolution de la génétique
d'ailleurs la spécialité elle n'existait
pas à l'époque quand j'avais entrepris
delà de la sphère et avant de parler
plus de génétique qui va être plutôt
bons sujets essentiels pour ce speech et
bien je voudrais d'abord insisté sur un
élément qui à mon avis est d'une grande
importance
c'est la place de la science dans dans
un pays la place que doit occuper la
science dans un pays tout pays doit
posséder la science et la technologie
sinon il restera à jamais tributaire de
ceux qui la détiennent regardons
l'histoire de l'humanité elle est faite
de quoi elle est faite par des
civilisations civiles successives et
parfois contemporaine qui se sont
imposés par le savoir et l'ingéniosité
de leurs citoyens
les exemples sont nombreux peuvent voir
les pyramides les pharaons et leur
pyramide carthage et son port punique il
reste unique au monde c'est déjà de 9
minutes
alors babylone et ses jardins suspendus
et ainsi de suite
il ya beaucoup d'exemples qui ont montré
que ces civilisations ont gouverné le
monde pendant des années à ce jour et
bien c'est l'informatique l'ingénierie
la biotechnologie qui est le propre
pratiquement de la civilisation
occidentale et qui en fait dès qu'ils en
ont fait d'elle une dominante et qui
fait des états unis les maîtres de ce
monde alors très rapidement je parle
certaine science qui sont très
importantes dans le domaine de la
technologie en application d'abord la
biologie moléculaire qui s'intéresse aux
vivants à l'échelle moléculaire pour
comprendre les mécanismes de
fonctionnement de la cellule et elle se
situe au croisement de la génétique de
la biochimie et de la physique et de
savoirs scientifiques l'ingénierie a
permis d'engendrer ce que l'on appelle
la bio technologie
deuxième exemple ce sont des
nanosciences qui correspondent à l'étude
de phénomènes et de la manipulation de
la matière à une échelle atomique
moléculaire et macromoléculaire et les
nanotechnologies
elles sont définies comme l'ensemble des
procédés de fabrication et de
manipulation de structures électroniques
chimiques ou autres de dispositifs et de
systèmes matériels à l'échelle du
nanomètre et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ces substances
elles sont créées et elles ne sont pas
naturels où elles ne sont pas le
résultat par exemple d'une d'une
combustion